[Music]
on this Wednesday night the young and
the fearless a message to the young
people you think you can't get too cold
that you can catch cold it the anxiety
over more Canadians letting their guard
down as the weather heats up who will be
allowed in and who will be banned the
complexities and the politics of
reopening Europe's external borders
battling Beijing's meddling this
includes is coming from a fairly
sophisticated network the criticism
Canada is not doing enough to stop it
and powering forward to the Hall of Fame
the beloved Canadian hockey heroes
scouring new honours
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
more regions of this country are easing
up on public health restrictions and
allowing people more freedom to get
together the four Atlantic provinces
have agreed to a so-called Atlantic
bubble starting July 3rd residents will
be allowed to travel between Nova Scotia
New Brunswick Prince Edward Island and
Newfoundland and Labrador without having
to self isolate for two weeks when they
cross a provincial boundary visitors
from other Canadian provinces and
territories still myself isolate for 14
days upon arrival in Ontario businesses
in Toronto and the Peel Region have the
green light to move to the next phase
that means businesses like restaurant
patios hair salons pools and indoor
malls can reopen and BC has moved into a
much anticipated phase 3 more on that in
just a moment this is all happening as
an alarming trend begins to emerge in
some places in Ontario there's been a
surge in Kovach 19 cases in people under
the age of 20 as Eric Sorenson reports
the young may be less susceptible to
getting sick but they can spread the
virus to those who are at greater risk
in Toronto restaurant patios are finally
open haircuts are available and daycares
are lifting restrictions and across the
country kovat 19 numbers are decreasing
on top of that it's hot outside not
surprising then that people are
gathering in greater numbers outdoors
but the virus is still with us
they elderly know that I made almost 80
years old so I'm going to be careful
young people however may be letting
their guard down as they socialize more
it's probably not ideal but also I mean
I know I personally don't have AC and
it's like 33 degrees today so I've not
interested in me anywhere else fairly
Toronto beaches were filled last weekend
with young people Ontario's premier is
worried about them I'm gonna give you a
message to the young people you think
you can't get covet you can catch colvin
the number of kovat 19 cases is falling
nationwide down 27 percent last week but
the age distribution is changing the
median age has fallen from 52 in April
to 40 in June the share of cases among
adults aged 30 to 59 has remained
consistent over time but while Canadians
/ comprised 36% of the cases early in
the outbreak that fell to 23% by last
week while the share among young people
up to age 29 has expanded from 19 to 32%
over several weeks the great outdoors
can alleviate the spread but an active
virus this summer could be a springboard
to a second wave we should enjoy because
when the fall comes there's a real
concern and if young people are
indifferent to the spread
epidemiologists worry there'll be a
source of increased transmission young
people though they're less likely to
have a serious reaction to this disease
are highly likely to spread it to those
who will have a bad reaction it's one
thing to be non or less vulnerable but
what that comes with responsibilities
that means protecting those who are more
vulnerable and there is a blunt warning
to young people and others if they widen
the spread of the virus Ontario's
premier says he'll move to shut down the
beaches this summer
Eric Sorenson Global News Toronto part
of one region of Ontario is still stuck
in stage one of the reopening plan
Windsor Essex across the river from
Detroit has more than 1300 cases of
kovat 19 including several outbreaks on
farms premier ford says most of the
region will move to phase 2 tomorrow
with the exception of Leamington and
Kingsville to reduce transmission on
farms there there's a plan to expand
on-site testing with a guarantee no
workers will lose their jobs if they
test positive access to employment
benefits and support and new guidance to
allow asymptomatic workers to keep
working safely without passing the virus
on British Columbia is transitioning to
phase 3 of its reopening plan BC
residents are now clear to travel
throughout the province there was never
an official ban but people were asked to
avoid unnecessary travel provincial
parks and campgrounds are reopening and
more hotels are expected to as well
British Columbians are encouraged to
take vacations this summer to support
the tourism and hospitality industries
though the public health officer says
precautions need to continue to prevent
the spread of kovat 19 south of BC in
Washington state there's been a spike in
new cases and
wearing masks in public is now mandatory
failure to wear one is a crime more than
4,000 people in that state are in the
hospital now with kovat 19 and one
hospital near Seattle has run out of
beds the situation is worse in some
other states as Jennifer Johnson reports
the rate of new infection is surging
back to where it was in April the u.s.
is reporting almost 35,000 new cases of
kovat 19 Wednesday levels not seen since
April Texas is breaking records Florida
to a staggering 5500 new cases in one
day we have large parts of the country
that are that believe that somehow the
pandemic is over that is going to get us
into a lot of trouble the governors of
New York New Jersey and Connecticut
once the pandemics epicenter are now
demanding any visitor from a high-risk
state quarantine for 14 days we have
taken our people through hell and back
and the last thing we need to do right
now is to subject our folks to another
round as cases rise in California
there's a new high-tech tool for
travelers at Los Angeles International
Airport the third busiest in the world
thermal imaging cameras checking
temperatures I think it's necessary 100%
rates are spiking in Arizona - or US
President Donald Trump rallied young
Republicans at a Phoenix megachurch
again using a racist name for the virus
Kongfu next month the federal government
begins testing of what it says is its
most promising vaccine a thousand people
in Chicago volunteering to get it that
could be the beginning of the end of
this god-awful pandemic the vaccine is
one of several in the works worldwide
but the virus is showing no signs of
slowing down and experts fear protests
earlier this month and the busy July 4th
holiday will keep cases surging Jennifer
Johnson Global News Washington the
European Union is expected to decide
this week how it will relax travel
restrictions to Europe allowing people
from some non-european countries to
visit this summer some countries may not
make the safe list though Brazil Russia
and the United States could remain
banned Redman Shannon is in London to
explain why it's far from a
straightforward decision for European
leaders Redmond
Danah anyone looking to travel from
Canada to the UK right now is obligated
to self isolate for 14 days but there
are almost no options for anyone looking
to travel from Canada to the European
Union the bloc that the UK left back in
January however come July 1st at the
height of the tourist season most of the
EU could reopen its external borders the
tricky decision for leaders there will
be which countries should they leave off
the approved visitors list
EU nations are haggling over what
criteria to use they are reportedly
going to look at the total number of new
cases per capita in the past two weeks
that's likely good news for people
coming from Canada but not for those
from south of the border US Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo was asked for his
reaction to the reports that travelers
from the United States would still be
banned we certainly don't want to reopen
a play that jeopardizes the United
States from people traveling here and we
certainly don't want to cause problems
anyplace else I'm very confident in the
coming weeks we'll figure that out as
between not only the United States and
the EU but the United States and other
parts of the world too of course the
number of cases in a country can often
be low because of a low level of testing
or because of unreliable data and that
will make this a political decision as
much as a safety one Ottawa could also
be faced with deciding whether to return
the favor to EU countries some of them
have much higher infection rates than
Canada the EU may announce the so-called
safe list of countries later this week
along with the measures that travelers
will have to take when arriving Donna
all right Redman Shannon in London thank
you the International Monetary Fund says
the decline in global growth is worse
than forecast it now predicts the global
economy will shrink 4.9 percent this
year that's significantly worse than the
three percent drop it predicted in April
it would be the worst annual contraction
since immediately after the Second World
War the IMF estimates Canada's GDP will
decline by eight point four percent in
2020 and that's a 2.2 percent steeper
drop than forecast two months ago the
IMF does expect a rebound next year as
long as there isn't
a second wave of koban 19 another risk
to Canada's future according to a
national security review is interference
from China an analysis by Global News of
the report found Canada is doing little
to combat increasingly aggressive
attempts by foreign countries notably
China who seek to interfere in Canada
and influence political and business
leaders even a perception of influence
is now under scrutiny
Canada's Foreign Affairs Minister has
repaid two mortgages he had with the
state-owned Bank of China after the
opposition criticized him for it
Francois Philippe champagne says the
mortgages never influenced his work but
as David akin explains China is
weaponizing investment and trade
whenever Huawei executive mung Wong Jo
makes a court appearance to fight her
extradition to the United States she is
cheered by supporters some of whom are
believed by Canadian security services
to be helped by Chinese agents operating
in Canada a global news investigation
finds that China is having success
undermining Canadian values often using
what China calls its United Front a
global influence and espionage network
that is active in Canada the Chinese
Communist Party has been very aggressive
in building up its network of United
Front organizations over the last viewed
that case China's government targets
elites in Canada such as business and
academic leaders but also politicians at
all levels and from all parties
sometimes they'll be offered sweet
business deals free or assisted travel
to China and other benefits as well as
institutions China's gold intelligence
experts say it's to get Canadian
influencers to advocate for Chinese
government policy in Canada Canadian
security officials have been warning
about this pernicious and dangerous kind
of influence for more than a decade
recently released national security
assessments indicate Canada is doing
little to counter these incursions by
the Chinese government
there is work to be done the Canadian
Security Intelligence Service told the
all party national security and
intelligence committee CSIS has assessed
that Canada is an attractive and
permissive target that all-party
parliamentary committee has put about 10
recommendations in front of the Trudeau
government that it believes can stop or
slow Chinese government influence in
Canada Donna
David akin thanks the huge plume of dust
over the care of the end coming up where
the dust storm comes from and where it's
headed plus the makers of a popular
herbicide settle a multi-billion dollar
lawsuit
a huge dust storm that started in the
Sahara Desert has blown all the way
across the Atlantic Ocean it's clouded
the skies over Puerto Rico Cuba and the
Caribbean islands and it's still moving
it's expected to cloud the US Gulf Coast
on Thursday and Friday and if the view
on the ground doesn't give you an idea
of how thick the dust is this is what it
looked like from the International Space
Station as it blew over the Atlantic
Ocean the German pharmaceutical company
Bayer is paying more than 10 billion
dollars to settle lawsuits over claims
the weed killer roundup made by its
subsidiary Monsanto causes cancer the
company has agreed to pay up to ten
point nine billion dollars u.s. settled
thousands of lawsuits Monsanto maintains
the herbicide is safe but the
International Agency for research on
cancer classified it as a probable human
carcinogen in 2015 settlement ends about
75 percent of the litigation involving
roundup but a number of other lawsuits
are still ongoing charges against a
First Nations chief in Alberta accused
of assaulting an RCMP officer have been
withdrawn dashcam video showed what
happened in a parking lot in Fort
McMurray in March after accusing a
Mountie of harassing him a second
officer runs that chief Allen Adham
grabs him by the neck and shoulders
tackles him and punches him in the head
the RCMP at first said the actions of
the officers were reasonable today as
Heather Eurex West explains that changed
chief Allen Adham is relieved of his
March arrest were captured by RCMP
dashcam
the 12 minute long video shows RCMP
officers approaching Adams truck its
license plate was expired Adam who was
not driving tells the officers twice to
go away when an officer goes to speak
with Adam the chief comes out of the
truck taking off his jacket he's told to
calm down and get back in the truck when
he does the officer grabs Adams wife by
the arm an officer can be seen grabbing
Adams arm and appears to be trying to
put it behind
back that's when a second officer runs
in tackling Adam punching him and
putting him in a chokehold
Adam was later charged with resisting
arrest and assaulting a police officer
but after reviewing the evidence both
charges were withdrawn Attorney
General's decision today chief Adams
view that the RCMP charges were laid as
a police shield to their aggressive and
abusive conduct not a true belief that
criminal activity had occurred the
Albert a serious incident response team
an independent body that looks into
allegations of police misconduct is
investigating whether RCMP members did
anything wrong that investigation was
launched earlier this month after chief
Adam went public with his experience but
he along with the Assembly of First
Nation regional chief say more needs to
be done to change how indigenous people
are policed please need to be
accountable to the people who serve a
search says its investigation will
continue if that investigation finds
RCMP members were not justified in the
level of force used against Adam
criminal charges could be laid Heather
your ex West Global News Calgary in the
u.s. three men have been indicted on
murder charges in the death of Ahmad R
burry a young unarmed black man who was
shot and killed in Georgia three white
men Gregory McMichael a former police
officer and his son along with William
Bryant have been indicted on malice and
felony murder charges in our buries
death the 25 year old was shot and
killed on February 23rd in Georgia in
may video was released showing what
happened McMichael told police he
believed our burry was a burglar
our buries family says he was just out
for a run still ahead the footage
fueling calls to change who responds to
911
an RCMP officer in BC has been placed on
desk duty and two investigations and a
lawsuit are under way it all relates to
what happened during what was supposed
to be a wellness check on a young woman
in kelowna wellness checks and how they
are handled are under scrutiny in this
country abigail Beeman takes a look at
what they are and whether who responds
needs to change and a warning some of
what you're about to see may be
disturbing dragged down the hall in a
Sports Bra when Mona Wang lifts up her
head you see the RCMP officer dropped
down her foot then later pulls her by
the hair I don't know why she kicked my
head down in the first place I think I
was just asking her a question and I was
on the floor already so why does she
feel the need to kick me when I'm
already down in court documents the RCMP
say the use of force was more than
reasonable and necessary Wang's
boyfriend had called 911 saying she was
in mental distress and this is just the
latest example of a call like that with
a disturbing outcome Agis Chaudhary was
killed by police this past weekend it
was immoral and wrong in New Brunswick
the deaths of Chantal Moore and Rodney
Levi all tied to mental health concerns
the Centre for Addiction and Mental
Health is now calling for mental health
specialists to respond to mental health
crises not police officers
if you hit chest pain at the end of
today god forbid you'd want somebody
with medical training to help you out
not a police officer criminologist
Jennifer Love Weis developing training
for police around mental health training
she says is badly needed a regular
constable is going to have to know how
to respond to a mental health call
because they they will happen in ways
that maybe are unexpected like check
well being a traffic stop a domestic
situation a trespass call many police
forces already work alongside mental
health specialists in mobile crisis
units the head of the Canadian Police
Association says there aren't enough of
them the findings of all of those
examinations are would eat more capacity
in the community to deal with mental
health issues
we support that but I don't think this
is an either-or proposition he says of
the 13 million calls police get a year
fewer than 1% involve use of force at 3
o'clock in the morning when somebody's
wildung a knife and they're suffering
from a mental health crisis that is not
the time to bring in mental health
practitioners it's time for the RCMP to
go in get that person calm get them to a
place of safety and get them the help
they need the head of the RCMP pushed
back against the idea of defunding
police rather funding more services
alongside it Abigail Beeman Global News
Ottawa
Scooter sign off a trademark two wheeler
hits a wall
after a bumpy two decades the Segway has
come to the end of the road
manufacturing of the Personal
Transporter popular with tourists and
police officers will stop July 15th
sales never really took off it was
expensive and could be dangerous in 2010
the company owner died after driving one
off a cliff
former Calgary Flames star Jarome Iginla
and five others are riding high tonight
they've just been voted into the Hockey
Hall of Fame
congratulations Jarome Iginla was one of
the NHL's most dominant power forwards
for more than a decade born near st.
Albert Alberta
Iginla made his NHL debut in 1995 when
he was drafted by Dallas before being
signed by the flames a year later again
like quickly stole the hearts of many
fans in Calgary leading the team's
scoring for 11 of the 15 seasons he was
there he ended his career with 625 NHL
goals the Edmonton Alberta native
recorded 1,300 points in 1500 and 54 NHL
regular season games Jarome Iginla was
just as big as start off the ice giving
much of his personal time to the
community into charities five other
players were also inducted into the Hall
of Fame today including fellow Canadians
Kevin low who played for the Edmonton
Oilers alongside Wayne Gretzky back in
the team's glory days and three-time
Olympic gold medalist Kim st. Pierre and
that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is Bird River Manitoba
northeast of Winnipeg beautiful sunset
we'd love to see you're at Canada please
email it to viewers at global national
comm thanks for watching and I hope to
see you here again tomorrow take care of
yourselves
bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]